오늘 빌사 아미 간다는 잠실 새
내역에 왔습니다
[음악]
잠실 새내역이 최근에 상권이 좀 많이
안 좋다라는 좀 얘기가 많은데 제가
한번 직접 가서 지금 상황이 어떤지
좀 보도록 하겠습니다 잠실
새내역이라고 여기 바뀐지가 얼마 안
됐어요 2018년도에 바뀌었는데 지금
서대문구의 신천동이라는 데랑 이름이
비슷합니다 그래서 사람들이 좀 많이
헷갈리기도 했고 그리고 저기 신촌
역도 있잖아요 그래서 신촌역이랑 신천
역이랑 매우 헷갈리기 때문에 잠실
내역으로 2018년도에 바꿨습니다
[음악]
네 어 잠실 새내역 변천사를 좀 세
단계로 분류를 해보자면 강남이 개발될
때 같이 좀 개발이 됐어요 그래서 한
7 80년도에 여기가 원래 잠실이
매립해서 만든 겁니다 원래
섬이었는데 때 매립을 하면서 여기
주거 시설이라 상가 시설이 들어오면서
여기 잠시 새내역 상권이 생겼습니다네
90년대에서 2000년도 여기 상권이
저는 피크라고 생각합니다 그래서 그때
이제 본격적으로 좀 개발되면서 여기
인근의 아파트들도 많이 들어오고 정말
잠실을 대표할 만한 사건이었어요 강남
강동 잠실에 정말 대표하는 건이었고
그때 당시 아마 유동인구가 가장
많았던 어 그런 사건이었습니다
2010년도 이후에이 롯데 타워가 어
생겨나면서 빨려 들어가기 시작했죠
그러면서 사람이 좀 많이 줄기
시작했습니다 결정적인 이유가 이게 좀
여기가 좀 개발이 되고 뭔가 여기만의
색기는 상권이 생겼어야 되는데
아직까지 여기가 좀 개발이나 이런
변화들을 좀 대비를 못했던 부분이
있는 거 같습니다 여기가 이제 상권이
예전 많치 못하다는게 사실 롯데 타워
가면 다 있거든요 맛집도 진짜
우리나라에서 제일 유명한 맛집들 저기
다 모아 놨습니다 그리고 뭐 편의
시설도 있고 영화관도 있고 저기 가면
모든게 다 해결이 되거든요 여기 지금
잠실 새내역 상권뿐만 아니라 방이동
국자 상권도 타격이 많이 커졌어요
그리고 그 외에 이제 잠실 상권 같은
경우에도 다 롯데 타워에 흡수가
됐습니다네 그러면서 여기 색깔도 좀
많이 죽고 여기 상권이 많이 죽기
[음악]
시작했습니다네 제가 오늘 설명드린
매각 사례는 잠실 새내역에서 바로
들어오자마자 있는 초입 건물입니다
그래서이 건물은 2018년도에
매입했는데 매입할 당시에는 3 4층
규모에 굉장히 좀 낡은 건물이었습니다
근데 그때 당시에 약 한 41억
정도에 매입을 해 가지고
2019년도에 지은 건물입니다 그래서
만실일 당시에는 임대료가 약 한
2천만 원까지 나왔습니다 신축하기
전에는 임대료가 한 약 한 800만
원 정도 나왔는데 임대료가 굉장히 좀
많이 상승했습니다 그리고 시세는 약
한 두 배 정도 늘어난 것으로
보여지는데 사실 강남이나 성수 한남
같은 경우에는 6년 전과 비교해서
가격이 좀 굉장히 많이 르긴 했지만
여기도 그래도 가격 방어도 좀 되고
수익성도 좀 괜찮게 나오는 것으로 좀
예상이 됩니다 지금이 건물 1층
임차인이 나갔더라 그래서 지금 위치가
굉장히 좋은데도 불구하고 지금 잠실
새내역 상권이 얼마나 위태로운지 현
상황을 보여주는 거
[음악]
같습니다 어 잠시 새내역 바로 이면에
왔는데 여기가 용도 지역이 상업
지역이에요 그래서 이런 호텔이라
모텔들이 좀 많이 밀집되어 있고
그리고 유흥 시설 허가가납니다
상업지가 그래서 여기 유흥 시설이 좀
굉장히 좀 많이 발달됐고 de 타워가
있는데 롯데 타워 같은 경우에는 한
밤 10시만데도 다 문을 닿잖아 근데
여기는 밤에 더 활발합니다 그래서
그런 점 때문에 직장인들이 좀 많이
찾는 거 같아요 밤 늦게까지 뭐
술이라 뭐 이런 유용 시설을 즐기기
위해서 좀 그런 점 때문에 잠시 새
뇌역 계속 좀 활발하게 움직이는 거
같습니다
여기 안에만 들어와도 뭐 1층은
근생이란 있고 나머지는 주택입니다
그래서 여기 위까지는 근생이란 때문에
위에 층은 주택인 건물들이 되게
많아요 지금 저 건물 보시면은 건물이
이렇게 생겼잖아요 그래서 하나는
일조건 사선 받은 거고 하나는 도로
사선 받은 겁니다 이면에 이렇게 좀
좁은 도로에 건물을 매입할 때 이렇게
건물들이 많거든요 근데 15년도에
도로 사선이 폐지가 되면서이 도로
사선 부분을 필 수가 있습니다 그래서
피무 인해서이 혜택들이 되게 많거든요
그래서 안에 내부 면적이 굉장히
넓어지기 때문에 진짜 도로 사선을
받냐 안 받냐는 굉장히 큰 부분입니다
그래서 저렇게 도로 사선 부분은 필
수 있기 때문에 여러분들이 사전에
저런 걸 좀 파악하셨나요
부분을 살리셔서 어 건물의 가치를
최대한 끌어 올리시기 바랍니다 이게
봐봐요 건물 이게 너무 위에 층이
비율 적이에요
그래서 여기이면 보면 이렇게 고시텔
건물들이 많은데 이런 고시텔 건물을
매입할 때 주의할 점이 일단 대출이
잘 안 나옵니다 주택 건물 같은
경우에는 방 하나당 최우선 변제금이
다 까져요 그래서 서울시 기준으로
최우선 변제금이 5,500만 원인데
고시텔 건 지금 이 정도 규명은 제가
봤을 때 한 20개 정도 있을 거
같거든요 방이 그러면 한 11억 정도
대출이 안 나옵니다 이런 고시텔
건물을 매입할 때는 반 개수를
파악하실 필요가 있어요 상가주택 건물
같은 경우에도 주택 면적이 상가
면적보다 더 큰 경우에 대출이 안
나올 경우도 있습니다 그 전체를 다
주택으로 봐요네 그래서 일부러 상가
면적을 주택 면적보다 조금 더
늘리기도 합니다 그래서 뭐 예를
들어서 뭐 일부층 잔금 전에 뭐
상가로 변경한다는 이런 거를 통해서
상가 면적을 일부로 반을 좀 넘게
해요 51% 정도 되게 예 그래서
여러분들이 대출받을 때이 주택 부분은
굉장히 좀 중요한 부분이기 때문에이
부분을 기억하셨다가 좀 투자를 하시면
좋을 것
[음악]
같습니다네 그래서 여기 이면에 되게
좀 오래된 노포 맛집들이 좀 많이
있는 거 같어요 좀 직장인들이나
학생들이 좀 많이 찾아오는 거 같고
그리고 금액 가 그렇게 높지가
않거든요 생각보다 그래서 좀 그런
부분 때문에 사람들이 좀 많이
찾아오는 거
같습니다 보통 여기 이면에는 이렇게
원룸이나 고시처럼 주어가 되게 좀
발달되어 있어요 그래서 차라리 진짜
근생다는 이런 주거 수여가 훨씬 더
많기 때문에 어 그런 거를 타케스
건물을 만들어도 좋을 거 같고 그리고
지금 여기가 여기랑 거리가 좀 멀지도
않고 그리고 잠시 새내역 2호선이
되게 좋거든요 그래서 직장인들이 여기
강남에 출퇴근하기 너무 좋습니다
그래서 여기에 그런 직장인 수요도
굉장히 좀 많기 때문에 어 이런
원룸텔이 좀 이런 고시텔이 좀 많지
않나 어 그렇게 생각을
합니다 그리고 저는 잠시 새내역
상권의 가장 큰 메리트가 뭐냐면 여기
앞에가 지금 그 야구 경기장이 있어요
야구 경기장이 있어서 정규 시즌 에
정말 야구장 왔던 사람들이 이쪽
상권을 많이 이용합니다 그래서 한
평일에는 한 만 명 정도 약 만명
정도 야구장을 오고 그 주말 같은
경우에는 거의 2만 명 정도가
야구장을 오기 때문에 진짜 걸어서 올
만 하거든요 그래서 그 수요만 해도
상당히 많기 때문에 잠시 새 내만의
뭔가 그런 어 특수를 누리고 있지
않나네 그렇게 생각을
합니다 그리고 여기 상이 또 좋은게
뭐냐면 저기 건너편이 그예요 여기에
병원이 좀 많이 들어와 있습니다
그래서이 건물 같은 경우에도 1층에
은행 있고 나머지는 다 병원으로
맞춰져 있어요 진짜 좀 배우 세대가
좀 탄탄한 거 같습니다 여기 일대
거의 한 약한 2만 세대 정도
있거든요 여기 임차인들이 좀 배우
세대에 들어올 법한 어 그런
임차인들이 좀 많이 있습니다 대로변
쪽에는 다 진짜 병원 많이 들어가
있어요 여기 맥도날드도 있고 하니원
[음악]
잠시 세내 역전 미래 전망을 하자면
어 일단은 지금 상황이 좀 좋지
않지만 지금 여기 건너편에 그 종합
운동 장력 개발 계획이 좀 있어요
그래서 지금 코엑스 지금 영동대로
지하와 같이 묶어 가지고 여기 일대를
정말 천지 개벽할 정도로 개발을
한다라고 합니다 그래서 제가 그
계획도를 좀 보니까 종합 운동장 역에
호텔들도 좀 들어와요 그래서
4성급이랑 5성급 호텔도 들어오고
컨벤션 센터도 들어오고 진짜 종합
운동 장력 일대가 정말 엄청나게
개발이 될 것으로 보여집니다 그래서
그 개발로 인해서 이쪽 상권도 어느
정도 좀 영향을 받을 것으로 좀
예상이 되고 그리고 무엇보다 좀 여기
상권이 좀 특색 있게 좀 바뀌어야 될
것 같아요 그래서 진짜 여기에 올
만한 이유를 좀 만들어 줘야 될 것
같습니다 사실 롯데 타워에 웬만한 건
다 들어가 있잖아요 롯데 타워를 굳이
가는게 아니라 진짜 잠시에 내형 에
뭔가 그런 상을 좀 특색 있게
만들어야지 여기 상권이 좀 유지되거나
아니면 더 발전되지 않을까 그렇게
예상을 합니다 어 제가 어저께 그
일론머스크가 나와서 하는 그 영상을
좀 봤는데 그래서 그때도 그 LA
다저스의 구장에 주차장이 너무 큰
거예요 그래서 그걸 이제 자율 주행
차로 바꾸면서 거기를 다 공원으로
만들겠다 그리고 차를 왜 거기다
파킹하고 주고 다시 돌아가면 되는
그래서 그런 걸 얘기하면서 전 되게
충격받았어요 근데 이게 좀 머지하는
미래라고 생각을 하거든요 그래서 지금
종합 운동 장력도 그렇지만 여기일 때
사실 주차장 면적이 굉장히 크거든요
그래서 여기를 차라리 공원을 더
늘린다든지
개인적으로 우리나라 그런 주차법
있잖아요 그래서 뭐 예를 들어서 근생
시설 같은 경우에는 134m 당
한대에 무조건 확보해야 된다라는 것
때문에 건물 모양이라 면적을 되게
비율적으로 쓰고 있거든요 근데 그게
앞으로 좀 바뀌었으면 좋겠습니다 건물
면적을 좀 최대한 확보할 수 있는
그런 건축 법들이 좀 개정이 됐으면
좋겠습니다 그래서 잠시 새내역
상권이이 종합 운동 장력 개발 계획과
맞물려서 과연 어떻게 변할지 여러분들
계속 좀 지켜보시면 좋을 거 같고요
오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 빌딩은
빌사남
[음악]
p